plateau mont royal mardi soir deux
jeunes militants préparent leurs
banderoles en vue de la grande marche
pour le climat de demain le 21 octobre
ils voteront pour la première fois lors
d'une élection fédérale
certaines tentent de faire tes son but
puis c'est vrai sexton on veut que la
façon dont les politiques sont faites en
ce moment que ça change donc le vote est
comme un moyen d'exprimer sa mobilisé
politisé ils suivent d'assez près la
campagne électorale je la sens moins
proche des jeunes que la campagne et
provinces à qui était faite octobre
dernier je sens qu'on vient - et nous
chercher com - nous parler un peu
je pense que l'enjeu qui l'environnement
n'est pas suffisamment de l'a20
l'environnement
c'est le mot sur toutes les lèvres des
millénaires you les 18 à 38 ans est ici
au pavillon jean brillant de
l'université de montréal
c'est l'enjeu rassembleur la protection
du territoire
parce qu'on habite dessus donc
l'environnement a beaucoup de bons jeux
qui les touchent comme ceux de
l'environnement par exemple et je pense
que par différents moyens on fait
vraiment mieux pour démontrer notre
intérêt collectif en 2015 18% plus
d'électeurs de 18 à 24 ans et 12% plus
de 25 à 34 ans ont voté par rapport à
2011 ce qui aurait contribué à
l'élection de justin trudeau
c'est parti moi je vote bloc uni déroule
mais en plus participer dans mon coeur à
70 km de montréal
nicolaj une producteurs laitiers de 28
ans a une vie bien différente de celle
des universitaires mais lui aussi ira
marcher pour la planète à montréal il ne
suis pas tellement la campagne
électorale par manque de temps dit il
mais il ira voter il faut s'exprimer et
puis si on va au moins on n'a pas de
voiture et chialer comme il dit il le
fait souvent contre les politiciens
encore cette année
lui et ses deux jeunes voisins dans la
vingtaine également agriculteurs se
sentent négligés qu'on entend parler
c'est surtout les publics les côtés de
les niaiseries xao puisque ce qui est
vraiment important puits car on parle de
l'agriculture on attend par la radio ou
à des médiaux je pense qu'on oublie je
pense qu'on le monde oublie ce qu'on
fait pour eux j'ai pas de préférence
mais maintenant que je voterai pas pour
les libéraux avec ce qui en fait avec la
gestion de leurs salles avec mon avenir
on retrouve pas l'intérêt d'aller à
choisir un partir parce qu'il y est on a
choisi total - pmf oppose la pause il
faudrait choisi le bon côté
autre réalité plus à l'est au centre de
formation professionnelle de
saint-hyacinthe une école de métiers
les jeunes ici se sentent assez loin de
l'ambiance électorale
j'en ai ce que je pensais que j'allais
aller voter mes deux premières fois je
suis pas allé voter mais je remarque que
chaque vote est important
et qu'at-il de la politique c'est des
impôts des enfants
c'est très important puis manu
environnement c'est très important voit
beaucoup les québécois comme des
bûcherons que je trouve que j'ai
peut-être une au fond c'est bien sa job
de faire paraître les québécois c'est
bien dans pointe du planet a lâché page
mbei sont censés vers google pendant
notre tournage touche sans exception ont
dit vouloir aller voter ce n'est rien de
scientifique mais une chose est certaine
les millé nario compte maintenant pour
plus du tiers des électeurs canadiens et
leur participation sera déterminante
dans les résultats de l'élection
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal